this is lemonhope part 1 I'm gonna
pologize for my voice by the way I just
got done with a convention and doing a
review and of course the smart thing to
do go to another convention immediately
after I'll see you kinetic on so but
this is actually can I give a quick oh
yeah that's right you don't know yeah go
ahead
I'm Jory you can join man if you wish my
Doug took us to anime Midwest it was a
whole lot of fun it was really neat
meeting some people and I just want to
say thank you to a whole bunch of them
because you made an average Joe like mu
just us is to help his friend out feel
like a rock star like it was super neat
meeting like a whole bunch of people
that just I don't know they made me and
Jory feel more than just the average
person we felt because you want more
than we felt wanted in its it's neat it
was really really neat and just a couple
people I want to say thank you to one is
MIA Aaron Thomas tuck no Tommy Tommy
sorry Tommy
I'm terrible Tommy and what's Jacob
thank you for the picture yes and then I
don't remember their names but it was
just two girls super sweet super nice
one of them was dressed as one of the
girls from most popular girl at school
so what it is pre most popular girls in
school I want to say thank you to them
super awesome girls and then a special
thank you and hello and all that stuff
to our our third daughter now our second
daughter no no I don't even know Amy
sorry can we get on to I'll think nobody
I mean you are all praising me as you
should be there's a billion other people
but like I I'm terrible with names
obviously so anyone ever than I am I
knew what I didn't say like I thank you
- I mean honestly from the bottom of
my heart thank you it you made me feel
super special like you made me feel just
like a million bucks thank you
it does remind me because somehow is
gonna break somebody maybe this little
tree trunks with a nostalgia critic hat
and tie on and I forgot to bring it so
I'll try to bring it next time I'm
really sorry but I just know that it'll
get on one of these I just totally
forgot so I'm sorry uh buh with that
said gone on long enough
till you get the candy right now you
take the bag yes okay don't move the bat
take your candy okay so okay so we have
a lemon hole part one just a funny
little upbeat adventure you know nothing
strange and at all
pretty much we see lemonhope who escaped
the London Kingdom or whatever it was
called no earldom yes he escaped and
bubblegum is trying to teach him how to
not be like the rest of the kingdom we
see this film strip where yeah it's
pretty much one lemongrab again he ate
the other one and he's kind of like a
fruit meanie a mussolini's and yeah it's
just it's it's pretty grim actually I
mean for like you know just every
episode of lemon grant seems to get
darker and darker and more pleasant yeah
and this one's no exception uh let me
know if it's supposed to be the one to
not be like them and hopefully one day
come back and deliver them from all this
terribleness uh but he doesn't want that
he wants no education wants none of that
and he kind of wants to be mean on its
own so he goes off on his own um and
finds a pirate ship in the desert and
gets on it but the next morning the ship
is kind of gone it's like just the
middle of it is left and everybody else
on is gone so he wakes up he's like Oh
freedom freedoms great but they has to
survive on his own and he's not very
good at it and the last thing you see is
him crawling in the desert starving to
death um so we secular road trip from
rage against machine I guess lemonhope
is going for
that's like is what he's doing for most
of it just not screaming it oh wait goes
back to his original home it'll stand up
Farid maybe I can do it better now that
the boys is grown me um so yeah it's
it's weird cuz I just got done doing an
editorial talking about like abstract
and surreal films and one of them was
like David Lynch so I had to see it sit
through a lot David Lee yeah so to watch
this again oh you know like after or to
watch this after all that straight yeah
cuz like Mohammed drive in a raise your
hand Lost Highway and stuff and just
watch this it's like I never left those
movies it's kind of like cuz there's a
lot of dream imagery in this uh a lot of
it actually pretty cool the opening a
dream sequence was actually even though
is very minimal was really pretty
actually like with the black backgrounds
of the colored doors and stuff ripping
off Super Mario Bros 2 yeah I did did
you just want to see like a potion go
down a pop up yeah so obviously it's a
set up for the next one so it's like you
can't entirely say whether or not yeah
that was a good direction or not because
if that I don't know the direction it's
going in um lemonhope it's kind of like
a mini Lemongrab um just not quite as
annoying and Lemongrab to get a few
laughs I like when the Eagle picks up
that one runaway drops inside just like
now I must eat you like doesn't even ask
what happened or anything just so in
drops in his room a sec so you got a few
laughs um but I guess I liked it it's I
just associated it with unpleasantness
though and I think that's the intention
don't get me wrong but it's really a
blessing
um so I don't know I I liked it I guess
I it's one of those things where I'm not
like go lemonhope I wanna see you
succeed because he is kind of annoying
but he's not he's not Lemongrab annoying
quite yet cuz he has a little bit of the
voice but doesn't talk as much so I'm
gonna happen
um but yeah that's kind of a messed up
way of talking about it's like a half
one that half day that I guess but yeah
I got to see where it's going but uh I'm
intrigued enough I guess
Jori it's dark I like it I like it a lot
although it's sad because I really am
kind of with you I really actually
dislike lemonhope he's really irritates
the crap out of me and it's like so
embarrassing because here's Lemongrab
who was like the worst of the worst he's
like the worst of all and I'm like ha ha
ha that's so funny that your brother
lemon is inside you still alive
screaming to get out you're just eating
every hope of all that's funny
but here's lemon Hope which is kind of
more human issues you know I mean he's
got the traits and you can kind of
excuse actually his behavior is what
he's a kid yeah kids don't do selfless
things because it's the noble thing to
do kids are kids you know you learn it
you you you have to learn empathy and
that's what bubblegum was trying to do
and so you can't I can't really blame
lemonhope but I just can't stand in it
he's so freakin irritating I don't under
you know and like this this journey to
see him like go through this
horribleness where he's all shriveled up
and then me hair catches on fire because
it's just so hot and it's like I just
don't care just die in a fire that's
fine keep going he's a kid but I want
him to die
the only other thing I really have to
say is I'm just curious you know
bubblegum is the one that created the
lemongrass
and she doesn't seem to care much her
rules I mean she cares about her rules
and she cares about what she wants to do
and what she thinks is okay so I thought
it was interesting that she's like home
because my first thought was like why
can't she just fix this she's the one
that made them fix it but then they're
on the hill and she's trying to show
lemonhope and she say but there's
there's a rule or a law or something
that she can't treaties and stuff we're
signed yeah that near the earldom and
stuff and it's like but you disregard a
lot of other stuff like we give up some
of our freedoms you do what you want
anyway
cuz them because remember there's that
one episode where she erased part of the
create how they create life yes but
there was a reason behind that okay my
only argument to that is when it comes
to the lemongrabs especially in this
society what does he do he flips the
hell out and he does crazy bizarre
strange things yeah she will break laws
or break rules or whatever but not at
the expense of another person's life she
may be kind of callous she may be kind
of like crazy or cuckoo wait a minute
what about that James episode the whole
thing was him getting sad was she yeah
she was able to clone him so yes it was
at the cost of his life but in the end
she could bring him back no problem this
is one of those where this is a
completely set it's like the u.s.
stepping on everyone else honestly that
was the first thing I thought yeah this
is Iraq with house shut off it is and I
think it's more the whole thing of if
she stepped in there without the whole
invisibility it could cause some of
these people their lives that she cannot
bring back yeah there's definitely like
I said just a lobby imagery in the setup
and everything I mean was something
little too close to you know really hard
stuff to figure out in real life with
governments and
politics and styles just going of it
you're not welcome here everything is
fine don't come yeah I have to say that
little yeah that's my favorite part of
the whole thing my favorite part was cup
cups and if you know what I was just
getting has nothing doing anything but
just I point out watching it I love how
at the end of the film strip there's
still the beep of the color bars even
though it's a film it's a little thing
but I love it's like how we still put
static in our online videos what
something's being interrupted even
though it's online that there would be
it's just it's such a great icon to
quickly go to it yeah yeah um one thing
I don't know if you noticed or not um
when she opens the drawer to get the
cupcakes
there's a mini mr. cupcake in there now
I'm a fan there's a mini myth I mean
doesn't have the arms or legs or
anything but yeah there's a mini mr.
cupcake in there um I can't stand lemon
I don't care what anyone says
little Brett and put then again he comes
from the lemon society he comes from the
lemon people where it's hard to defend
but it's hard to like the other lemon
people obviously gave him freedom they
knew like they weren't all about
themselves they knew that they could you
know help someone else so just saying
that he's a lemon person and that's the
reason why oh it's okay I guess I mean I
don't accept that
himmat being a kid I can accept that you
know he's a kid but at the same time
it's like when he's doing his little
song and he goes up oh my god that was
the worst the worst that stupid song he
pokes the owl in the head that knocks
over his water that is he's climbing up
he knocks over the nest of eggs like
he's just gonna you know what it reminds
me of the Futurama episode where it's
freedom day where you can do whatever
you want to and it doesn't matter
there's like bender knocking people over
I think you broke my leg freedom you
know all that stuff like that's what
like lemonhope is doing he's doing
whatever the hell he wants
and kind of sing freedom I have freedom
to do whatever I want to freedom freedom
and it's like well dude you can say that
but you know really well I'll say this
the one thing I can't remind me of I
think everybody as a kid you know it has
a fancy about it's like wanting to run
away like I run away from my mom and dad
a new life and Gilligan's Island or some
crap
but you know but there's always this
thing and then like either no kid ever
really does it or even those that do get
like up lock down the road it's like
yeah I don't think so and then they
can't really do it and I sort of saw
this I guess like as an extension of
that I mean just the idea of like
running away and not taking the
responsibility at all you know much like
a little kid does like how do you do
this because nobody's timed me - so you
would act like a little kid with like
you know just smash things and stuff
like that side about me too much but
maybe it's the fact that he is just so
minimal and what he says and the way he
says it and what he says is so annoying
that it is like it's hard to it's
already minimal and then what he says
it's annoying so it's really hard to get
attached to the character yeah yeah I
didn't quite as much as quite as much as
Lemongrab but me is because he spoke
less I while watching it and recourse
brought it up an angry with or
completely the boats and all that stuff
reminds us of the anime stands of
destruction
we're basically almost all the waters
dried up and they sail across sand like
dates and oceans which is pretty neat so
I saw that's kind of what we saw in it
um but what I guess annoyed me and I I
don't know it's so small I know but when
he comes out he's like yeah I
accidentally got on your ship I'm
looking for help it's like dude you ran
you hit on that ship you liar liar no
your help you know that's like badly
that's like breaking into someone's
house eating their food and what I'm
going up see I accidentally ended up
here
I don't think he was asking for help he
was demanding it yeah say I think I need
help he said I'm going to I'm it's
something about I I'm just missing you
got upset by the like you know you
lawyer it's like it's alright you forget
things knocking over like the bird's
nest with the eggs and stuff I'm a it's
like you flipped he's all about freedom
of a bear leaves freed aligned well then
the cloud is free to not ring yeah yeah
I guess I bet falls under that he's he's
a kid has never known you know freedom I
I guess it makes a little bit more sense
to see where he came from with that you
know sort of background of being in that
terrible place and he's like well I do I
have to hear more about this terrible
place if they made this place can say
it's like he just wants away from
everything he does he keeps going to one
extreme cuz he's lived in such an
extreme and but it's still in extreme
he's going into so it's gonna be
extremely bad I just like saying extreme
what's bubbled I'm showing him though
filmstrip oh yeah he she's basically
saying to him because these people gave
you freedom you need to come back and
help them at some point in time look at
how much they are suffering
yeah she says basically they're being
punished because they helped you because
they're being like more tortured and
it's kind of cruel to in a sense of her
to say that yeah it is cruel to say that
to a kid but at the same time you should
instill that in like young lemonhope
that they're suffering for you you need
to help them it's something they helped
you you need to help them at the sink
like go come back and help them and he's
just gonna like it whatever and I think
you're right
these guys giving doodles and stuff he's
a kid I get that but at the same time I
don't know as much as I hate old people
and I hate you know kids and whatnot you
just hate humanity walked by a building
on fire and I saw like you know someone
in the building saying help me I'd help
I mean if it's a little baby or me
that's true I was made of it everyone we
screwed you know I know to help even
when I was a kid you have that sense of
helped other people you know no matter
for to an extent no matter how badly you
grow up you know there's kind of I don't
know maybe I don't know I hate people
hey well she's burning in a building
hahaha
it's a building in your building yeah